i've got two experiments online on my
website sheldrake.org
at the moment um one of them is
a joint attention test and here i'm
exploring something
i don't think anyone else has ever
explored it's it's um the question is
if you have two people concentrating on
the same thing at the same time
oh nowadays with me mass media we can
have millions of people
concentrating watching the same tv show
for example watching the same
football match um millions at the same
time
is there a kind of resonance between
minds when people are watching the same
thing as someone else
this hasn't got a standard scientific
word i i call it joint attention
we know we know that joint attention
actually joint attention is established
because
when babies reach the age of about one
they become capable of joint attention
and it's a very important part of normal
development
that's why with people with babies and
toddlers they go around they'd say doggy
and they say oh yes doggy and and you
it's
joint attention on the same thing is
essential for human
development uh proper if people who
don't have this turn out to be autistic
very often
so it's about our shared world anyway
in my joint attention test um
you log on online and with another
person
um in a separate place and then there's
a series of trials where in each trial
you're showing a picture
you're just watching the screen a
picture appears and
at random your partner may be sharing
the same picture or a different picture
there's a different pair of pictures for
each test
um each car lasts only 10 seconds the
whole
whole test lasts three minutes so um
then uh what you're asked after 10
seconds
one of the people is asked was your
partner looking at the same picture
okay and you click saying different
you're right or you're wrong by chance
you'd be right fifty percent of the time
yeah in these experiments it's coming
out significantly above chance it's not
a very big effect but it's very
significant
are we talking 55 60 what are we talking
about we're talking
in this case only about 53 54.
with thousands of trials it's okay it's
it's very significant
yeah and anyway i'm doing a new test
comparing different kinds of pictures it
seems to be working better when you're
looking at
pictures of faces than landscapes for
example
perhaps because it's more interesting
so that's one of my experiments looking
at a new phenomenon
and then of course i want to scale it up
what happens if you've got 10 people
looking at the same thing yeah
50 or 100. and of course you could do
this live on tv as well where you could
do it with millions
yes yes this would have an enormous
effect in interpreting what's happening
in modern culture which involves huge
amounts of joint attention
yet this is completely unexplored
because the standard materialist
assumption in science is that minds
are nothing but brains and they're
insulated inside heads
so what you're thinking and looking at
has no effect on me
at a distance because that's impossible
your mind's nothing but the physical
activity of your brain
the second experiment that i'm running
which i invite people to take part in
is an experimental test of telephone
telepathy
more than 80 percent of the population
say that they've had experience the
experience of thinking of someone
who then rings and they say that's funny
i was just thinking about you
or they just know who it is when the
phone rings
before they've looked at the caller id
or answered it with the phone
it's very very common experience um it
works
especially well with people who know
each other well telepathy is about
people who are bonded socially now
for a hundred years or more since the
invention of the telephone
people have observed this but the
so-called skeptics
the dogmatic skeptics have said oh well
it's impossible that it's really
telepathy that can't happen because
minds are just inside brains
it's impossible for them to have an
influence at a distance it's nothing but
coincidence and selective memory you
remember when you're right you forget
when you're wrong and so on
anyway i've developed a test to test
that
and how the test works is you register
on my website
sheldrate.org you put in the names of
two
friends or family members people you
know well and their telephone numbers
the computer then at a randomized time
picks one of these two people at random
calls them up
so say i was doing the test and you were
one of my callers
yeah so my wife jill was the other one
and you get a call saying this is
rupert's
telephone telepathy test please think
about rupert when you're ready
press one you press one my phone then
rings
the corner id says telephone telepathy
test
it says one of your two corners is on
the line right now waiting to speak to
you
press one for alan press two for jill
so i then say who i think it is out of
these two people
and as soon as i guess that's recorded
on a database
the line opens up and i get instant
feedback
as to whether i'm right or wrong and
then i can talk for up to a minute it
cuts off after a minute because i'm
paying for the call
and um
and um this test is giving you know
very significant positive results in in
my earlier versions of the test i had
four callers
and there the chance rates 25 and we
were getting
uh rates at average rates of about 45
percent
you know with hundreds wow massively
significant statistically
yeah and this so this uh what i'm trying
to do at the moment
is to find out if people can get better
at this by practice
and if so how they practice how they can
develop their intuition
so what i'd like to say to anyone
listening to this is if you're in the
u.s
canada or uk or italy the test doesn't
work anywhere else at the moment
um then check it out try it with your
friends it doesn't take very long
about 10 minutes for your time to do one
of these tests spray spaced over an hour
and a half or a couple of hours
and um this if
i'm inviting people to try and find how
to train their intuition
i don't know how to train i'm not that
good at these things i score above
chance but i'm not brilliantly intuitive
so i'm asking other people to help with
this and and
in fact it could turn into a competition
who's got the best intuition
yeah a global competition and they could
it could even end up if people find they
can practice and get better at it
it could even end up with a telepathy
olympics olympics
who's the most person in the world yeah
and then i think when we get to that
stage all these boring old skeptics who
just know it
possible the evidence isn't there it
doesn't exist this would i mean
they'd still exist but they'd become
like the flat earth society
yes fringe group they are a fringe group
anyway but
they pretend they speak for the the
science establishment they don't really
but they pretend to
anyway here's a way forward
yeah yeah this yeah that that you're
what you just
summarized there with the joint
detention study in the telephone
telepathy study
was basically the essence of what i was
getting at with
actually when you plant a flag beyond
the edge
and then further is you actually you
yourself
create the tests to further prove
the hypothesis and then try and inspire
other people around the world to not
only create
not only participate in your test but
also create their
own tests to try and prove these
hypotheses
and also i actually really appreciated
the
i think the structure of the two
that you spoke about it's very important
first of all the joint
attention study i i really like how
for both of them that you can
crowdsource people from
around the world well us uk
and uh australia and
that's the telephone one the joint
attention test works everywhere so
everywhere so so this is this is a big
deal because if you can get people from
india and brazil and russia and all
these other countries around the world
that are
that can that can do the
uh you know joint detention one and
beyond let's see if we can get people
around the world doing
these i appreciate how i think the
structure rupert that you were
describing
as somebody that is also a fellow
science scientist science advocate
science communicator
um it's just for me to for me to view
the the style of your experiments
it sounds quite robust and in the sense
of
um even getting even getting small
incremental differences of training
intuition
you can't you can't pick up a basketball
and just walk onto a court and start
shooting three-pointers you can't pick
up a violin
and just start playing mozart you you
you have to train your intuition
you have to train these telepathic
abilities in order for you to
bump up like if in that example where
there's you know
four in telephone telepathy if there's
four options of my four
friends and if on my rate is only
supposed to be 25 but if i'm hitting
45 that's significant and that's also a
big deal
if i'm um slowly trying to compete if
i'm becoming
the united states best uh most intuitive
telephone telepathist
and then i'm competing against the
united kingdom's and germany's and
and china's and i think that's a very
interesting style of
of trying to you know if if rupert if we
can take
that flag beyond the edge of what's
known and if we can
incentivize people to partake through a
sports
style olympic style process
like what you're teaching i think that's
also very fun and it's engaging
and also the joint detention thing has a
lot to do with the modern day
uh we're approaching all 8 billion
people soon to be connected
on the planet and if you can release a
piece of content
and then watch how people
watch the content and if they can tell
if they're if other people that they're
engaging with if this person if
if rupert is also watching the um the
advancement that's been made in biotech
or if rupert's watching the advancement
that's being made in blockchain and
cryptocurrency and then
i pick which one rupert's you know
watching
and i think that's very interesting
given the fact that all eight billion
people are now
we can there's a collective zeitgeist
that's happening
all the time with this pacer of the
cycle of media absolutely
well i think this is that's why i think
it's so topical at the moment the whole
question of joint attention
there's never been a capacity for so
many people
to have so much joint attention and
now everyone agrees of course that we're
interlinked through the internet and
through news media and through radio and
television and so forth
but the big blockage to these inquiries
within
institutional science is this
materialist assumption the mind's
nothing but the brain
and that's why no one's doing research
on this
um it's also one reason why i've
uh i like doing research in the public
domain
and i like doing it outside universities
and where anyone can take part
but it's also that i'm forced to work
that way because these
subjects are so taboo there's almost no
university where you could actually do
this
research and hold down a job and you
know
because the the opposition to these
things is is very very strong
from dogmatic materialists i mean most
ordinary people are not opposed most
ordinary people are
interested in these phenomena but within
the academic world there is this problem
of
dogmatic materialism anyway i
tried just to get it go go on doing
research and and get on with these
experiments
there's enough people who participate
for the results to come in